und nicht fallen lassen nicht rutschen
lassen schön aufpassen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen Kuchen der nicht
gebacken werden muss ganz ohne Mehl mit
Zutaten die ihr wahrscheinlich überall
bekommt oder vielleicht sogar zu Hause
habt ein no big Cheesecake so sieht er
jetzt bei mir aus ich finde der ist
richtig hübsch sie tatsächlich so ein
bisschen festlich sogar aus ich habe
hier einen leckeren Keksboden mit
Mandeln und Keksen bisschen weiße
Schokolade ist mit dabei darüber eine
Frischkäsecreme und obendrauf Lemon
gehört ich liebe ja Zitronen ich liebe
Lemon Curd und die Torte ist auch von
der Zubereitung her gar nicht so
schwierig mit so ein paar Tipps und
Tricks gelingt sie euch auch richtig
schön und ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal
die Zutaten für den Keksboden damit
geht's nämlich los dafür verwende ich 50
Gramm gehackte Mandeln 125 Gramm Butter
180g Butterkekse 100 Gramm weiße
Kuvertüre und den Abrieb einer Zitrone
ich gebe jetzt zuerst die Mandeln in
einen kleinen Topf oder eine Pfanne und
lasst sie rösten einfach einfach ohne
Fett
so bei mittelhoher Hitze
und dann kann ich hier die Kekse
zerkleinern entweder gibt es jetzt
einfach eine große Schüssel und geht mit
dem wacker rein oder in eine Tüte mit
dem ausrollstab oder einfach in einem
kleinen Mixer das geht auch hauptsache
die sind dann zerkleinert
[Musik]
Abend
und die Mandeln jetzt einfach so lange
bis sie eine schöne Farbe haben
da mache ich jetzt den Herd aus und gebe
direkt die Butter mit dazu damit sie
schmelzen kann
und sobald du dein geschmolzen ist kann
ich hier auch noch die weiße Kuvertüre
dazugeben da reicht einfach die
restliche Hitze auf jeden Fall aus damit
sie schön schmilzt
lass mal kurz stehen und kann hier dann
schon noch Zitronenabrieb dazu geben
wird ja ein Lemon Cheesecake deswegen
soll auch der Boden schön dass Zitrone
schmecken und ich finde Zitrone und
Mandel Pasta echt perfekt zusammen
[Musik]
hier alles geschmolzen ist einfach alles
schön vermischen
[Musik]
und dann habt ihr hier diese wunderbare
krümelkeksmasse und könnt sie jetzt hier
in den Tortenring reindrücken ich habe
den jetzt schon auf 25 cm eingestellt
dann einfach eine Backfolie drunter
einen tortenretter
und schön alles hier rein lernen
und wenn ihr eine etwas höhere Torte
haben wollt dann verringert ihr einfach
den Durchmesser aber ich finde so von
der Größe her passt es gut da kann ich
die Torte später nämlich auch schön
dekorieren
hier gut reinfüllen und verteilen und
dann am besten mit einem glasflacht
drücken oder zum Beispiel mit der
burgerpresse das mache ich tatsächlich
am meisten geht nämlich am schnellsten
[Musik]
so
dann stelle ich den schon mal kalt und
kann in der Zwischenzeit die
Frischkäsecreme machen
für die Creme verwende ich 400g
Frischkäse eine Prise Zitrone und Abrieb
etwas Zitronensaft 80 Gramm Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt 500 Gramm Sahne und Sahne
zum steif schlagen jetzt verrät ihr den
Frischkäse mit dem Zitronenabrieb und
Zitronensaft je nachdem wie säuerliches
sein soll dürft ihr jetzt den ganzen
Zitronensaft nehmen oder einfach nur so
ein bisschen ich nehme natürlich den
ganzen und Puderzucker und
Vanilleextrakt kommt da auch gleich mit
dazu
[Musik]
und wenn die Zutaten hier dann schön
cremig sind einfach noch Sahne zu gießen
und mit seiner Bad steif schlagen
richtig schöne schnelle leckere
Zitronencreme
[Musik]
fertig
da hole ich jetzt mal schnell den Boden
der ist nämlich schon kalt
dann gebe ich jetzt hier ungefähr zwei
Drittel der Creme direkt rein und das
restliche Drittel das ist dann für die
Deko dann schön verstreichen am besten
mit einer Palette
[Musik]
und die restliche Creme fülle ich jetzt
schon mal einen Spritzbeutel da habe ich
hier so eine große Rosetten Tülle und
die Fülle ich jetzt ein und kann dann
die Torte abgedeckt und auch die Creme
abgedeckt einfach im Kühlschrank stellen
so für etwa 2 bis 4 Stunden 2 Stunden
reichen auf jeden Fall auch schon aus
denn durch sein apart werden die Torten
immer sofort standfest das heißt sie
muss jetzt einfach nur schön durchkühlen
und ich kann dann aber auch schon mal
gleich die Zutaten richten fürs Lemon
Curd
[Musik]
da muss man immer den Kühlschrank öffnen
fürs Lemon Curd verwende ich ein Ei 50
Gramm Zitronensaft den Abrieb einer
Zitrone 50 Gramm Zucker einen Viertel
Teelöffel Stärke und 30 g Butter okay
jetzt gebt ihr fürs Levant alle Zutaten
in den Topf außerdem Butter die kommt
ganz zum Schluss rein und ich nehme da
immer gerne auf den kompletten
Zitronenabrieb damit es richtig schön
zitronig wird
die ganze Zitrone mit rein
und hier beim Reifen einfach immer nur
drauf achten dass die Zitrone nicht
behandelt sind dass man die Schale mit
verzehren kann und dass ihr beim
abreiben den weißen Teil nicht mit
abreibt weil sonst wird es bitter und
das schmeckt dann nicht so gut den Saft
habe ich ja schon ausgepresst also hier
einfach alles schön mit rein und dann
gut verrühren und die Zitronen die Masse
dann das Lemon gehört dann auf dem Herd
einfach einkochen
so beim Mittel hoher Hitze ungefähr das
ist eine kleine Menge ihr könnt auch
direkt die dreifache Menge machen oder
die vierfache und könnt einfach das
Lemon gehört noch abfüllen und in Gläser
Stellen in Kühlschrank dann habt ihr
immer einen schönen Zucht Aufstrich
[Musik]
dann ist die Masse jetzt fertig hier
kommt die kalte Butter noch mit rein die
muss man nicht mitkochen
so kühlt es ja auch schnell die Masse
herunter und dann streicht die Sie
einfach durch den Sieb falls eben doch
irgendwie noch Stückchen vorhanden sein
sollten dann ist die Masse nämlich schön
passiert
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr das
Lemon Curd auch gerne einfärben denn ich
finde für die Torte da sind Stich oder
ein bisschen gelber sein ich nehme jetzt
einfach ein bisschen Kurkuma und rühre
das ein und dann gibt es so ein schönes
gelb oder ihr könnt auch
Lebensmittelfarbe nehmen
[Musik]
dann setze ich jetzt erstmal die Torte
auf eine Tortenplatte das immer
einfacher wenn noch der Ring drumrum ist
dann könnte ich hier die Backfolie
drunter weg
[Musik]
und dann den Ring entfernen
jetzt wird die Torte fertig dekoriert
und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür meinen
torteneinteiler und portioniert die
Torte schon mal bisschen vor dann habe
ich es bei der Deko gleich etwas
einfacher
so
dann nehme ich einen Tortenring oder ihr
könnt auch einen Teller zum Beispiel
nehmen denn ich will jetzt diese Sahne
Tupfen schön ringsrum drauf spritzen und
einfach damit ich weiß wo ich Ansätze
brauche ich hier so eine
Markierungslinie die mache ich jetzt
hier
und dann bekommt ihr die Sahnetupfer
schön gleichmäßig drauf also jetzt
einfach hier den Spritzbeutel schön
senkrecht halten und ich mache jetzt das
ganze ringsrum das heißt das in der
Mitte Platz ist für Slammer gehört das
wird dann so als Spiegel rein gefüllt
[Musik]
und dann habe ich jetzt hier mein warmes
Lemon Curd und das kommt jetzt hier
direkt in die Mitte also es darf nicht
mehr heiß sein aber es soll auch noch
nicht kalt sein denn es soll ja auf der
Torte erstarren
[Musik]
die lege ich jetzt einfach auf so ein
bisschen Küchenpapier und tupft sie ab
damit sie eben nicht Wässern auf der
Torte
und dann könnt ihr mit diesen
Zitronenspalten und mit bisschen
gepufftem am Rand einfach die Torte
fertig dekorieren und dann ist es eine
richtig schöne schnelle einfache
zitronentorte
schaut wie wunderschön sie ist Diana
und die Torte und die Jutta
die kommt jetzt noch in den Kühlschrank
und ich habe die Hoffnung dass mein
Lemon Curd gar nicht so fest wird
deswegen habe ich da auch recht wenig
Butter dran damit später beim Anschnitt
das so ein bisschen so ein bisschen
runter läuft wisst ihr wie ich meinen so
so richtig schön aber die kommen jetzt
noch kurz in Kühlschrank damit alles
schön durchkühlt und dann kann ich kurz
aufräumen und dann wird probiert
und nicht fallen lassen nicht rutschen
lassen schön aufpassen
Murat und Tim wollt ihr probieren
ich habe eine Zitrone Torte gemacht
so Matthias hätte ich mir einiges klar
wollte ich nur sagen so ja
da kommt immer rüber zum Spielen
genau
rüber da kommt da immer spielt mit viel
bessere Idee
[Musik]
mach doch Ding drauf mach doch hier
zuckerfrei
jetzt hast du gar keinen zitronenanteil
auf deiner Torte
das heißt wenn jemand Amaranth wer kauft
es eigentlich wo kriegt man das
überhaupt
überall also
sag mal die Kamera Kommentare ob ihr
schon was von Amaranth was gehört habt
und was ist eigentlich bringen soll weil
es schmecken tut ist doch gar nichts die
schmeckt nach Styropor es geht zum
Alnatura ehrlich glaube ich noch ein
Stück mit Lemon Curd
kannst schon mal sagen wie es schmeckt
gut ne
ich habe mich auf Instagram gechillt mit
stefanozzarella jeder backt nobic
Cheesecake mit Zitrone und ich weiß
nicht was er backt er weiß nicht was ich
backe aber ich hoffe natürlich dass
meine Torte besser ist
du hast bio-zitrone genommen dann kann
man die Schale essen ja macht es auf
jeden Fall oder ein anderer kleinen
kleiner Tipp von mir ihr könnt die
Zitrone auch so crusty machen weißt du
knusprig ist was machen wir backen fährt
oder was machen wir da neben tust du mit
Zucker und dann mit Zucker antrocknen
dörren zum Beispiel okay und wenn so
crush crispy ich wollte sogar noch
machen mit den oben drauf ja es wäre
cool
ja aber ihr könnt gerne wenn ihr wollt
die Zitronenscheiben hier noch ein
bisschen Zucker im Dörrautomaten stecken
und dann habt ihr so knusprige kandierte
Zitrone
ich mache jetzt Kaffee dann setzen wir
uns raus jeder kriegt noch ein Stückle
Torte kriegst dann auch einen ganzes so
und das Rezept findet ihr auch
sallys-blog.de oder in meiner App du
kannst auch ein Stück Torte mit nach
Hause nehmen
100 %
schnell mal runter
ist auch der war ein Praktikant sechs
Monate bei uns jetzt machen seine
Bachelorarbeit und dann kommt dazu uns
wieder zurück wir haben ihn süchtig
gemacht er kommt immer wieder zurück und
er ist noch Single 22 Jahre alt
[Musik]
er hat ein Bachelor fertig gemacht ist
21 und ist noch Single
und schafft ist selecon Valley
macht's gut bis bald kennenlernen
[Musik]